uh but it's lovely and now you know
we're on the uh we're on the eve of
returning to the dump that we live in
and i'm not really thrilled yeah
i'm really you know i i i could make a
go of it here
there's an ashtray on the thing i'm
covered how about you worry about you
worry about the sound levels
uh i can make a go of it here man i'm
kind of bummed to leave
i mean you know
as we're here the country of origin
our country of origin
is just
it's a deeply schizophrenic
place
there's a real darkness there
that can only be truly appreciated when
you leave
now i'm sure this place would get boring
after a while because you know
i don't know it lacks
some of that
but for right now for the moment i mean
i just i'm kind of dreading
going back to america
the food here is good like you don't
feel like you're dying
when you eat
they don't have sugar in everything they
don't have like plastics
in the bread
like they're just hormones the gmos the
manipulated
[ __ ] that we
eat
they got fast food here they put it all
on like one street it's not every five
feet
things aren't open at two a.m to get a
full meal
the lifts are smaller
which is elevator for you [ __ ]
american scumbags you don't know what
i'm talking about
the streets are smaller i mean you know
you just it's it's uh
being fat is not really tolerated
it's not tolerated and it it
you get it there's no big and tall
stores there's none of that you can't
get anything
i mean it's like we drove an hour to
some store i thought it'd be like a dxl
it was called bad rhino
think of that it was called bad
rhino
and it was not even a full store it was
just like a few shirts
in a fat women's store
in a shitty mall
an hour and a half out of london
they and i get it they're like let's not
celebrate that
you know i mean
i i i'm completely for that by the way
they're like let's not make it easy
we don't want it to be they had a dxl
here an american fat store they closed
it down
because you know like
it's not permitted and if you go further
into europe like paris or something i
mean or if you go to scandinavia god
help you
but i mean we're staying at the mandarin
oriental which is one of the greatest
hotels in the world if not the greatest
it's absolutely stunning and the uh
building next to us is the the famed one
hyde park where you know it's the most
expensive residential building in the
world the penthouse is on the market
right now for 200 i believe 296
million pounds and i might make an offer
i don't know i don't know if i will or
not
uh but you know it's a building full of
russian oligarchs and you know uh i i
believe maybe
the candy brothers who developed it they
might be in business with the qataris i
think
and um
it's just lovely
it's just lovely nobody's there nobody's
ever home and there's very few lights on
um because the best neighbors are not
home i mean that's something that
you know people don't realize but that's
why in all these really rich areas
you know you have a great situation
because the best neighbors are always
off somewhere doing a genocide like
they're not
they're not home they're not there to
complain
you know you don't have awkward run-ins
with them
outside you don't have to suffer through
small talk with people who are driving
past you in their lamborghini to go into
a bulletproof glass garage all of their
mail is getting sent through an x-ray
machine they're being guarded by the
equivalent of british special forces
none of those people oddly enough
want to tell you what they think about
everything
but i've lived in lots of
areas
where people cannot get enough of your
time
what's nice about russian oligarchs
uh sheiks
people from the united arab emirates
uh chinese amusement park tycoons people
russian gangsters in the uh fertilizer
business
indian mining magnets you know
uh brazilian uh uh mining magnets maybe
it's brazil that has the mines i don't
know but like you know what's really
nice about them is they really keep
their opinions to themself
they are less they don't even want you
to know that they are your neighbor what
a lovely idea
now there's a premium to live in a
building like that there's one flat on
sale flat means apartment for you
american uh non-healthcare having scum
suckers that i have to see tomorrow
but uh flat is
in an apartment and there's one flat on
sale for five million don't think i
didn't call my business manager we can't
do it it's too out of range but
um and then the next one up is 17
million but that is the premium that you
pay that is the premium that you pay to
live in a building where people don't
want you to know they also live there
could there be a better arrangement
seriously could there be a better
arrangement
in life than living in a essentially a
hotel
for uh billionaire criminals
they keep to
themselves
they don't bother you
they don't they don't oh what oh the
what do you think about the game huh
what do you think about these uh trans
kids in the schools
they don't get into that
right from the lambo to the apartment
that's it
they're not just going off on whatever
the issue of the day is
they don't get on a soapbox they're not
trying to be heard
they're not getting you in the hallway
did you see tucker
you know
what they're doing now
is they're making kids transition
in gym class
see you can get away from all that i
mean that is the answer it is the only
answer and you know people are going to
get mad at me again they're going to go
well
how am i supposed to live in one hard
part well that's not my problem i can't
manage your life i can't even live there
i'm just saying as
as things go
as goals go
it's a much better situation for someone
like me who's just a little tired of
people's opinions i'm a little tired of
the unsolicited opinions of friends
neighbors family co-workers uh you know
i i am now seeing the value uh in the
type of privacy that can only be
attained uh by living uh with dictators
who have a healthy degree of paranoia
because many people want revenge on them
for the things they've done it's a nice
place to live it's a lovely and then you
know i like the guy from the spectator
who came to the thing he's very sweet
but you know he's [ __ ] on one hyde
park and that guy lives in what putney
or
scumsberry hey shut up like what are you
talking about oh you can't live there oh
knightsbridge why would you want to live
there hey hey shut up and i like him but
let's get real
if i come to london and i may this is
the only spot for me i can't live
anywhere else
harrods is such a great [ __ ] store i
don't fit in anything i went to
christian dior and i said i'll spend any
amount of money do you have a three axe
and she said she did
let me tell you right now the 3x would
not have fit you
i went into the dressing room with the
3x
it was like i mean
putting that on it was like i was on
ayahuasca
shapes were changing
i couldn't get my bearings i'd stepped
into another realm
i felt like i was on i didn't know my
hands looked bigger and smaller i was
trying to fit into this 3x and it was
mortifying and it was terrible i could
because you know the uk it's different
than america
it's very different the sizes here and
finally i came out and of course i
didn't come out wearing it because i
would have looked absurd
i came out and i was like oh you only
have a navy blue i wanted it in brown
and she's like we don't have it in brown
i'm like thank god
and i just ran out of there
but our agent likes harrods which is
interesting because he's plus size and i
wouldn't think he'd like harrods but
then you go they have three food courts
in harrods so i go oh
they're also selling rib eyes and sticky
toffee pudding
so i get why he likes it
but you know
i mean this is just a place for me i've
i've had enough ben's watched the
masters for the last 10 hours
uh you know it's it's uh
it's a lovely place to be
you know and then uh you know
then you just keep checking twitter in
america and everybody's fighting about
uh disney
you know
people just screaming
there's people outside of disney with
the ten commandments
so you know again i just i i think i
want to get citizenship somewhere else
no i'm dead serious i want to get
citizenship somewhere else i don't think
it works out and i kind of don't want to
be a part of it anymore whatever it is
on both sides on the side where it's
like they think every teacher is a
groomer trying to [ __ ] their fat
children
and on the other side of like we should
let three-year-olds uh you know cut
their dicks off in the middle of math on
both uh on both sides i can no longer
participate in my country i really don't
even want to it's become an
embarrassment to live there
um it's become an embarrassment to live
in a country
where
many of our major streets are lined with
tents that people live in but all of the
uh all of the headlines are about when
hotels are gonna open in space